une poignée de commerçants sur le bord
de rivière en colère malgré de multiples
réunions avec les responsables de
l'entreprise grèce chargé de
l'exploitation de la ferme éolienne de
beauséjour
les dénominations qui leur avait été
promise n'a pas été honorée pourtant
disent subir les conséquences liées aux
travaux de la ferme
depuis le mois de mars yade et les
routes sont coupées
et puis il y avait les travaux des
éoliennes
et quand les gens arrivent au niveau de
beauséjour l'ast est barrée et ont
besoin de me tall n'avons commencé une
négociation depuis le mois de mars en
présence du sous-préfet de trinité des
élus de la chambre de commerce et tous
les commerçants de grand bien et il
avait été dit que une enveloppe était
allouée aux entreprises dont il vient
comme une enveloppe a été alloués aux
pêcheurs
quand il y habite une quinzaine
d'entreprises ne font partie du
collectif qui réclame une indemnisation
de 100 mille euros c'est sur la base de
leurs marges bénéficiaires que leurs
indemnités aurait été calculé sauf qu'à
l'époque c'est avec un autre directeur
que cet accord avait été acté le nouveau
lui propose après une matinée de blocage
la moitié de la somme
voilà vous voyez vous écoutez moi
j'étais témoin vous avez entendu la
femme et vous voyez que monsieur sur le
port les nerfs sont à vif il est socio
professionnelles ne comprennent pas
pourquoi les pêcheurs ont été indemnisés
et pas eux de plus l'arrivée de nuit ici
avec le responsable de l'entreprise
grèce ne va pas calmer les esprits faute
d'éléments je dis bon je propose quelque
chose un peu cohérent avec ce qui avait
été fait avec les marins pêcheurs à
savoir 50000 euros puisqu'on avait donné
5000 euros à chaque pêcheur ils sont
vingt cinq cent mille euros et par
ailleurs 5000 euros audi
socioprofessionnelles ce qui fait
cinquante mille euros
et ça reste est homogène parce que
demain il faut une forme de commandes de
cohérence et de moments de solidarité
puisque derrière si je donne plus les
pêcheurs s'étaient fleisher qui
viendront que je retrouverais ici
la tension est vive chez les commerçants
de go rivières et les heures de service
auto de la ferme éolienne gaspiller le
collectif a rendez vous de mai à 14
heures pour une réunion avec le préfet
et la société grèce en attendant les
socio professionnels sont décidés à
camper sur place jusqu'à ce qu'ils
obtiennent gain de cause